he's saying give him hell enough is
enough and then you had uh Omar suan
stepping up and telling him to go to
hell this nonsense this this oppression
that's been happening to the Palestinian
people for decades now if if not more um
is is something that obviously is it's
very sad to see that the American people
have not woken up to this yet
alhamdulillah by the by the grace of
Allah subhanahu wa taala and the means
of social media uh YouTube and these you
know uh uh smartphones and so on and so
forth I think a lot of people have
somewhat more access definitely more
than than before because before you'd
only get the standard narrative that
you're going to get from that part of
the world regarding as to what's
happening between the Israeli
Palestinian conflict as they'd like to
put it when in reality it's it's not the
Israeli uh uh Israeli uh Palestinian
conflict it's the oppression the
Injustice the ongoing
injustices that keep perpetuating
against the Palestinian people